even if we did achieve what we wanted
with a very small state we just be
resetting the clock back to 1776 and it
would roll forward exactly the same way
again
I'm Matt Welch I'm here for recent TV at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and I am
pleased to be joined today by stefan
molyneux you are the founding hoo-ha of
tell us about your radio station it's
freedomain radio sort of freedomain one
word freedomainradio.com my basic
argument is the consistent application
of the non-aggression principle and a
respect for property rights leads you to
a stateless society you know kind of
like it or not and so you could call
that sort of anarcho-capitalist and the
anarcho being no rulers and the
capitalism pot being respect for
property rights this seems to be a
growing tendency out there in the world
is that your impression - in America
there's more discussion along these
lines I think the way that it's been
going is that there was hope a long time
ago there was this little flower you
know in the state has just come along
and squished it if the energy that that
was provided to the movement by Mises by
Roth but by Rand by you know all of the
real founders of the movement I think
gave people a lot of hope and and the
you know the Goldwater campaign of the
Reagan movement even the Gingrich
movement in the 90s people had a huge
amount of hope that we could use the
last sue principles to bring down this
charging bison of the state and I think
in sort of the 20 25 years since there
was a real resurgence in libertarian
political activism and I think quite an
effective resurgence I mean the
Libertarian Party didn't do hugely well
but its influence on the Republican
Party has been enormous I think and it
really has not worked in any way shape
or form and the government is what five
to eight times bigger now than it was in
the 70s when the movement started with
the goal of reducing it and so and its
growth seems to be you know it's it's a
permanent yeah I mean it's massive and
it's ever increasing so I think people
are saying there's something wrong with
the political approach there's something
wrong with trying to restrain the beast
called the state right you know that is
already making the compromise to begin
with like you're seeding the territory
by you know well the agreement yes
school vouchers is is selling out yes
most school vouchers it's just a way of
you know giving the public sector unions
more control over private schools in the
long run
think that's the way it's gonna work
right my theory is that if you look at
the big scope of history you've got
small government's that crop up for a
variety of reasons from time to time
either ideologically or a government
collapses or there's some war which
leaves a territory vacuum in the middle
or a power vacuum in the middle roam
start is the smallest government of the
time with you know real focus on trade
and infrastructure and am you know
minimal interference in trade to prove
to be a massive empire if you look at
England when it started experimenting a
free trade what grew out of that was the
British Empire if you look at America
which is the experiment of the smallest
conceivable government what grows out of
that it's the largest government the
world has ever seen and my argument is
when you have a small government you
create free trade you create the you
know classic sort of von museum or
Austrian economics argument which is
that if you don't interfere you get
massive efficiencies you get the correct
or rational allocation of resources
through the price system without the
interference of the swords of the state
so when you have a small government you
get a huge amount of free trade you get
a massive growth and wealth and then the
government goes mean that's quite a lot
of wealth and so it starts to scoop and
scoop and scoop and the taxes can go up
and it can also use the wealth that's
being created and it's tax powers as
collateral for borrowing right and then
once the government can borrow it can
buy votes in the present by selling off
future generations which is kind of
where we are now so my argument be even
if you do collapse the state to
something very small you then create
this huge growth in wealth which the
government will then use to grow and so
I think my argument is even if we did
achieve what we wanted with a very small
state we'd just be resetting the clock
back to 1776 and it would roll forward
exactly the same way again and the only
way to break the cycle is not to lower
the dimmer switch but you know push it
and turn off the light well that's about
the most persuasive argument of Anarchy
that I've personally heard so really
congratulations good it's hard would you
like another one I'm getting squishes
it's not so easy I would love it if
politics worked and and if education
worked and and I mean wouldn't that be
great because it's not to talk to people
about a small state is a hugely
different conversation than to talk to
people about no state and so you know
it's sort of the difference between
saying to someone I think you should cut
down on your food
or saying you shouldn't eat it off
that's how people sort of receivers they
like I should cut down on my doughnuts
or whatever no food at all are you crazy
and so if and particularly in
libertarian Objectivist circles you know
like the Holy Trinity of the small state
right the police the law courts in the
military people will say let's shrink it
down to that they can still conceive of
how would work but when you start
talking about you know private dispute
resolution agencies private defense
agencies I mean there's these short
circuits that go off in people's heads
and suddenly the matrix just shimmers
and they sort of you know turn inside
out and it becomes a really challenging
conversation but I think that it's
something that needs to be discussed
because it would be a real shame if we
were chasing the government back down to
something small that then becomes a suit
like you know how stars that collapse
and then they go supernova that to me is
real the real cycle we crush the state
back down again through incredible
efforts of blood and propaganda and and
reasoning and argument and you know
fractured relationships and Wars and all
that and then it just keeps blowing up
again so I just really interested at
least exploring on how we might be able
to break that cycle shimmering the
matrix here in Las Vegas with stefan
molyneux thank you very much for recent
TV i am that way